[Applause]  a latino parents oh man they didn't care  about us we showed up to the party with  them we didn't leave until they left  it's three o'clock in the morning i had  to go to school tomorrow  and they didn't even put us in a bed no  no they made a bed for us right we got  the chairs together  you wanna go to sleep lay down go to  [Applause]  [Music]  we grew sleep tough my dad was a tough  person to grow like he was my first  bully you know what i mean  i want you to make this lawyer tengos  i'm in the soccer field freaking hell  the fight  i was the goalie i was like how the hell  [Music]  you had a tough life ah  i'm the immigrant but he has their tough  life  you